[Musique]
bienvenue dans pôle it mag spécial
élections municipales les français ont
la parole pendant toute la campagne à
travers des reportages sur le terrain
vos remarques et notre sondage sur nos
réseaux sociaux et puis bien sûr notre
débat aujourd'hui on va parler du mal
logement en france avec nos invités sur
ce plateau
jacqueline rue au spécialiste du
logement à l'association familles de
france face à vous jean baptiste eyraud
président de l'association droit au
logement
et puis renault et stein maître de
conférences à sciences po saint germain
en laye spécialiste de l'urbanisme
merci à tous d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt france le logement est
une des préoccupations majeures des
français en particulier pour ceux qui
vivent dans des zones de tension
selon l'insee l'acquis pour la france
compte 3 millions de logements vacants
et 4 millions de mal logés
illustration dans le nord de la france
nos reporters sont allés à lille et à
poubelles reportage est signée estelle
farges éclaire nico regarde
on se trouve ici à lille devant les
locaux de l'association magdala une
association qui vient en aide aux plus
démunis et notamment aux mal logés
c'est quoi est mal logés concrètement
être mal logés concrètement je pense que
c'est habiter dans un logement où on n'a
pas forcément l'eau chaude être dans un
logement qui est envahi par les souris
par exemple être dans un logement qui
est sale qui a été loué salle ce qui
n'est pas toujours le cas des bailleurs
sociaux mais qui est plus le cas
j'allais dire des bailleurs privés
malheureusement est d'être un train dans
un logement très exigu trop petit voilà
je pense que c'est ça être mal logés
dans les locaux de l'association nous
avons rencontré emmanuel après avoir
connu la rue et grâce à la vie
associative
il a trouvé un logement décent j'en suis
content voilà encore parce que le monde
de la russe et c'est très dur moralement
physiquement aussi
ça vous n'auriez pas pu le trouver tout
seul non non je pense pas étant donné
que quand on fait maintenant une demande
d'appartements sociale
comme hlm tout ce qui est lmh ou partie
nord est où il ya des années il y en a
il ya là ils mettent des années à à vous
fournir un appartement que même en ce
qui concerne un studio cours bonjour
nadine héritage
moi je paye normalement avec l'apl je
paie normalement 450 euros c'est un
propriétaire privé
ça fait un nom celui-ci c'est par
l'autre qui viennent les souris oui
s'ils passent par un trou de la
douchette ah oui oui comme menacée voilà
aussi tout comme ça c'est insalubre et
qu'est-ce qui vous répond votre
propriétaire quand vous lui parlez des
problèmes de votre appartement ben mon
propriétaire alinghi exactement qu'il
peut pas faire les travaux c'est pas un
mois c'est pas lui de les faire vivre
rien accepté donc aux oeufs d'or s'est
passé en france quand même corps en 2018
selon la fondation abbé pierre dans les
hauts de france près de deux cent mille
logements étaient considérés comme
potentiellement indignes et voilà pour
ce constat jean baptiste eyraud
évidemment il ya pire mais en tout cas
15 millions de personnes sont concernées
par cette crise du logement vous
confirmer ce chiffre 4 millions de mal
logés
c'est énorme ça fait près d'un quart de
la population qui est concerné par cette
crise du logement
oui enfin un peu moins d'un quart mais
oui c'est que aujourd'hui on est bloqué
on a une situation qui se dégrade
on a de plus en plus de personnes dans
la rue de plus en plus de personnes qui
sont logés dans des en situation de
surpeuplement en situation de
cohabitation contrainte parce que
souvent on dit ça qu'est ce que la
cohabitation contre bas vous savez cette
histoire des colocations pour les
étudiants pour les jeunes une forme de
bizutage ses rebonds on arrive en a plus
on peut cuire à son logement faut vivre
avec d'autres gens bon alors c'est pas
mal en même temps parce qu'après tout on
peut dire ça favorise le relationnel
mais je pense à dure 10 ans 15 ans bon
je veux dire on arrive dans la vie
active et on est encore en colocation
oui là aussi on est sur une forme de
pour nous de mal logement en tout cas
voilà et puis aussi les enfants qui
grandissent et qui restaure parents qui
n'ont pas d'autres solutions qui sont
partis un moment puis qui reviennent
bon c'est très dur ça la cause de tout
ça on va connaît on sait la cherté du
logement
voilà les prix et les prix qui sont
chères il ya d'autres causes il ya des
mesures aussi qui ont été prises par le
gouvernement pour tenter de résoudre en
tout cas le cadet des sans abri renault
eckstein vous qui est urbaniste on le
dit les logements sont chères
aujourd'hui de plus en plus cher
notamment et dans les grandes villes on
va le voir on a des chiffres justement
sur ces personnes qui ont du mal à
trouver un logement à quoi c'est dû
c'est une volonté politique de ne pas
faire ou de ne pas inciter à mieux
construire à construire davantage non
peut-être juste probablement une petite
précision sur les chiffres si on se
réfère au rapport de la fondation abbé
pierre qui est un peu nous la référence
à ces questions de mémoire c'est 4
millions de malhonnête c'est à dire 6 %
de la population française et 12
millions de personnes
l'expression s'est fragilisée par
rapport au logement edern dans cette
catégorie à deux choses très différentes
à des personnes qui sont bien logés mais
lyon un effort financier pour leur
logement qui est très élevé j'attends
les personnes qui sont en situation de
précarité énergétique surpeuplement donc
attention sur les chiffres 1 4 million
je pense que le chiffre de 4 millions de
mal-logés un chiffre qu'elle il faut
faire référencer 6% de la population
qu'un sens et la crise du lait
en général on arrive avec des formes
très très très très différents mais par
ailleurs ça veut dire que quand même les
français sont dans l'ensemble bien logés
et toutes les enquêtes notamment celles
de l'insee nous rappelle qu'on est aux
alentours de 80% des français qui disent
qu'ils sont satisfaits ou très
satisfaits de leurs conditions de
logement et ça il faut avoir ces
chiffres aussi parce que il faut se
souvenir que ça n'a pas toujours été le
cas
hollande quand l'abbé pierre fait son
insurrection de la bonté et appelle
surfait son appel sur les conditions de
mal logement
on est dans une situation de véritable
crise du logement qui est une crise à la
fois quantitative parce qu'on n'a pas
construit depuis le début du 20e siècle
parce qu'il est dommage de guerre et une
prise de mon gars me tâte yves parce que
le patrimoine est très dégradé de ce
point de vue là la politique qui a été
menée pour aller très vite
la fin des années 50 jusqu'à la fin des
années 70 a résolu la crise quantitative
du logement en france mais aussi quelles
sanctions maintenant ça a vieilli depuis
ça vieillit effectivement alors
maintenant pour voilà mais c'était un
premier point maintenant pour revenir à
votre question donc jeu il n'y a pas de
volonté politique de qe du mal logement
en revanche il y a eu énormément de
volonté on s'est peut-être pour
améliorer les choses
alors il ya yahia je ne pense pas qu'il
ya un manque de volonté mais il ya au
moins deux choses c'est d'abord que
le politique il ya plusieurs niveaux et
qu' il ya l'état il ya les régions il ya
des départements il ya des
intercommunalités
il ya les villes et qu' il peut y avoir
des intérêts très différent très
différents certains maires peuvent avoir
intérêt ou penser qu'ils ont intérêt à
ne pas construire ou reconstruire que
certains types de logements est alors
qu'à d'autres niveaux il y aurait
d'autres intérêts donc il ya des
problèmes d'ajustement et des maires de
communes riches font pas vouloir avoir
deux
logements sociaux et des rats et c'est
donc ça je pense pas que voilà
évidemment il ya il ya une politique du
logement on peut questionner cette
politique de logement je pense qu'on
leur donnera l'occasion de le faire dans
ses orientations
est ce qu'on donne la priorité au
logement privé au logement logement
social quel type de logement social puis
surtout où on construit parce que ça va
être une des difficultés dans toutes nos
discussions et dès qu'on parle de
logement c'est qu'on parle de manière
générale mais surtout parce que les ya
pas un marché du logement en france il
ya des marchés du logement
l'homme la situation à dreux pourquoi on
connaît ma voisine
évidemment rien à voir à celle qu'on va
connaître à quelques kilomètres de là en
banlieue parisienne et on a des
situations à la fois d'hypertension
marché du logement dans l'agglomération
parisienne dans la métropole de province
un pack adam dans dans le sillon alpin
et des situations de la situation que
vous avez montré à roubaix ce n'est pas
une situation dans lequel il n'y a pas
assez de logements
on est plutôt dans des situations de
territoire en déprises et où là la
question du logement s'exprime dans des
termes très différent il faudra faire
attention tout au long du débat bien ça
bien bien spécifié dans quelques de quel
contexte on pas jacqueline rio vous qui
êtes à dreux justement quel est le
constat que vous faites en matière de
mal logement est ce que les choses
s'amélioreront pas là on a eu 1 on a un
quartier qui s'appelle les batkin
horreur donc il est en rénovation il va
il va avoir des bâtiments cassé mais bon
en attendant ces personnes qui sont dans
des appartements où il ya des ouvertures
de 3,4 centimes est où la pluie rentre
où il ya des punaises où il ya des
et enfin des blattes enfin c'est quand
même incohérent que c'est pour jean il
reste et puis les enfants vivent dans
cette humidité où ils sont atteintes aux
poumons
vraiment c'est dramatique comme ça c'est
un quartier en particulier de tre et
c'est quelque chose que vous voyez un
problème que vous voyez augmenter ou
finalement qui arrive à trouver des
solutions il n'y a pas que des bailleurs
il ya du privé ont là cette année j'ai
jamais eu autant de maisons ou
d'appartements qui était indécent ou qui
étaient insalubres ou des murs tombent
et carrément c'est ça fait peur et moi
je suis responsable au niveau national
et je pensais que c'était dû à ce petit
monde parce que voilà il y avait eu
beaucoup d'industries qui en a plus
maintenant
non c'est ça existe à rouen ça existe à
marseille ça existe à dijon c'est
partout là elle est la difficulté à les
l'aller l'ancien voilà qu'à en parler
aux gars de l'insalubrité qui amenait
aussi à des drames on l'a vu on va
écouter pierre medec qui est grand
spécialiste évidemment du marché
immobilier économiste à l ofce et au le
gouvernement a pris des mesures pour
essayer de trouver des solutions avec
son plan logement d'abord un voyez ce
qu'en pense pierre medac et on en débat
après le gouvernement a deux grandes
mesures sur le logement la première
mesure c'est le plan logement d'abord
qui vise à accueillir les ménages sans
domicile et à leur proposer un logement
c'est à dire on sort de la logique de on
propose à ces gens là des solutions
d'hébergement temporaire mais comme son
nom l'indiqué la priorité c'est de leur
donner un logement donc ça ça va plutôt
dans le bon sens après il faut voir
qu'il ya un manque de cohérence du
gouvernement parce que dans le même
temps on fait un certain nombre
d'économies budgétaires notamment sur le
parc social et les apl qui sont de
grands pans de la politique du logement
qui sont faits pour favoriser l'accès au
logement et le maintien dans le logement
des ménages les plus modestes
donc le plan logement d'abord c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle encore faut-il
que les objectifs soient remplis
par contre toutes les mesures qui visent
à faire des économies sur parc social et
les aps plutôt des mauvaises mesures
entre
quand on regarde leurs conséquences sur
la capacité des ménages pauvres à
accéder au logement donc il ya à la fois
des bons côtés des mauvais côtés
voilà ce qu'on pense à pierre madec jean
baptiste eyraud le on l'a entendu pierre
madec dire le gouvernement fait des
économies sur le parc social c'est à
dire c'est à dire que il a eu un
gouvernement
est arrivé avec la ferme intention de
réduire ses dépenses sociales bon donc
je crois financer la baisse des impôts
donc on tape sur les apl en gros gars
d'économies par an mon pour 2019 2020 en
ont un peu moins un peu plus fin et donc
une partie de ces économies sont faites
directement sur le dos des locataires
hlm
enfin deux locataires aux règles
générales ou c'est du secteur privé à
commencer par les moins 5 euros et puis
une autre partie je sais de l'ordre de
1,2 milliard qui sont retirés en fait
aux bailleurs sociaux puisque l'état
leur verse - d'apl et en même temps le
loyer des locataires qui touchent l'apl
doit rester le même sur le loyer
résiduelles ce qui reste à payer le
loyer net donc
donc voilà c'est ça le principe donc les
bailleurs sociaux se retrouvent avec 1,2
milliard d'euros en moins dans les
caisses
donc ce qui veut dire ce qui a pour
conséquence évidemment une baisse de
l'entretien dos des travaux lourds
d'entretien même de l'entretien
quotidien
ça veut dire aussi une baisse dans la
production de logements de nouveaux
logements sociaux
bon mais c'est surtout savoir d impact
surtout dans les quartiers populaires
hlm là où précisément
l'apl donc c'est là qu'il va y avoir le
moins d'argent reverser donc
automatiquement automatiquement des
bailleurs sociaux avoir tendance à se
défausser dans ces quartiers là donc
c'est dans les quartiers populaires hlm
soul et qu'on risque de voir une rapide
des dégradations des conditions de
logement
donc ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point moi ce que je veux dire
c'est que la situation elle a évolué on
est d'accord depuis mai elle s'est
dégradée à partir on va dire du courant
des années 80 à partir du moment où on a
commencé à déréguler les loyers les
loyers qui était bon ok gérer votre 48
tout ce qu'on voudra
c'était très bas ok bon en tout cas
cette et bah ça permettait pas aux
bailleurs privés d'entretenir
convenablement patrimoine ok mais on a
dérégulé même
progressivement et donc on en est arrivé
aujourd'hui à des niveaux de loyers très
élevés qui impacte les classes
populaires les ménages modestes et les
classes moyennes
si on l'a vu dans les grands alors paris
cetera les classes moyennes mais donc
les conséquences et que pour les pour
les ménages modestes ils vont consacrer
30 40 50% de leurs revenus voire plus
donc ils vont faire des sacrifiés sur
rend la défoncer la santé l'éducation
on les loisirs mais sur des postes qui
sont des postes fondamentaux j'irai un
la santé éducation et puis maman donné
ils vont ils vont ils vont se retrouver
un impayé de loyer donc 130000 peu ou
poutre 120 à 130 jugement d'expulsion
par an ça fait quand même sur dix ans
ces massifs ces massifs
c'est 1,3 million à 2 millions voire bon
un million de ménages mai
ça fait beaucoup sur 12 ou 13 millions
de locataires bon donc on est sur un
processus aujourd'hui d'exclusion rapide
par le logement même jusqu'à 60% vous
parlez de la part consacrée
voilà l'annoncé la question de la cherté
du logement c'est qu'il ya pas qu
durement quoi je veux et les inégalités
se sont accrues parce que les ménages
les locataires sont moins cons sont de
plus en plus issus des classes
populaires parce que ils ont pas la
capacité de transférer leur patrimoine
et d'acheter alors d'une descente dans
un produit non pas ce qu'il ya avant les
classes populaires est plus souvent
propriétaires de leur logement
elles le sont moins en moins parce
qu'ils peuvent pas transférer leur
patrimoine
parce que dirait soit il faut accrocher
la maison au clou pour payer la maison
de retraite médicalisée
c'est une option l'autre option c'est
que si on arrive à leur fils à ses
enfants en bas âge max oui on aurait pu
non surtout les enfants ça suffira pas
pour qui se loge donc il va falloir
qu'ils achètent des pièces en plus et
c'est donc c'est un choix compliqué des
pièces en plus qui vont leur coûter très
cher donc si vous voulez le les classes
populaires sont plus en plus contraints
dans le secteur locatif et dans des
situations évidemment de comment
dirais-je où ils sont pas exploitées
mais qui sont vraiment à la main des
bailleurs et lesquels bailleur qu'est ce
qu'ils veulent ils veulent pouvoir
augmenter les loyers pouvoir les virer
quand ils veulent
pour changer de locataire pouvoir vendre
le logement le plus facilement possible
avec le mois d'occupants l'intérieur
parce que ça va se vendre plus cher s'il
est vide c'est à dire financiarisé le
patrimoine immobilier
on va écouter le chargé d'études à la
fondation abbé pierre il ya aussi une
autre une autre donne aujourd'hui
écouter le 35 % des ménages français
sont composés d'une seule personne c'est
nouveau c'est devenu le modèle
majoritaire en france donc ça il faut
que le parc de logements le modèle de
protection sociale s'adapte à cette
nouvelle donne très importante et on
sait que le parc de logements s'adaptent
très lentement et qu'il est encore très
stéréotypé très standardisé autour de la
famille avec enfants alors qu'en fait
c'est devenu un modèle minoritaire ou à
la renault gitane cette question est
pour vous évidemment le modèle même de
société a changé
il n'a pas évolué en fonction de
finalement des logements il ya de plus
en plus de personnes seuls 35 %
donc forcément c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué d'accéder et de payer son
loyer quand on est seul est-ce qu'il ya
suffisamment de d'offres par rapport à
cette demande selon vous visiblement non
ceci étant dit la halle à ce que ce sur
quoi insiste emmanuel d'homère et je
pense qu'elle qu'il faut toujours à
l'esprit c'est l'extrême et inertie du
marché du logement
vous pouvez dès choisir de si on a une
épidémie de coronavirus c'est très
facile ou quoi relativement facile de
produire 10 fois plus de masques
produire dix fois plus de logements
vertement et donc ça coûte un peu plus
cher et donc l'adaptation du parc de
logements par le flux de production
neuve est toujours lent très lent et se
pose la question de alors il ya deux
questions d'air sa première question
c'est comment on fait évoluer le parc
existant
c'est compliqué mais bon c'est une des
pistes et on voit des logiques de 300
sessions sont les vrais noveko bâtir du
neuf je passais plus compliqué mais en
tout cas rénové pour changer la
typologie la structure bats et
d'immeubles d'appartements de 5,5 ps ou
adaptés à des familles à plusieurs types
de logements c'est sans doute plus
compliqué que produire en série comme on
l'a fait au moins la construction mais
deuxième chose qui me semble extrêmement
important sais c'est que la question de
l'adaptation du parc de logements aux
besoins justement ce n'est pas ça ne
peut pas être une question d'offre de
production neuve et de ce point de vue
là c'est une des questions qu'on peut
qu'on peut adresser au gouvernement au
delà de ce qu'est ce que ce que vous
avez dit sur la réduction des apl est ce
que ça plus produit la dégradation
décoder des capacités financières des
bailleurs sociaux qui produisent moins
qui produisait en moyenne moins pour le
moment surtout qu'ils produisent moins
c'est la production qui qui qui chute
pour le moment et sachant que la
production la chute de la production hlm
a des conséquences très directs sur la
chute de la production privée parce que
l'évolution majeure qu'on connaît depuis
une petite dizaine d'années c'est qu'on
ne produit plus d'un côté du privé de
l'autre côté du hlm mais on produit dans
les mêmes immeubles du logement social
et du logement du logement privé et donc
quand les hlm ont moins d'argent
les promoteurs n'arrive plus à eux mêmes
après à produire et donc il ya eu une
sorte de paradoxe alors que le mouvement
ah non c'est un choc d'offre on a plutôt
exactement aujourd'hui l' inverse
mais ça c'est du côté de la production
neuve l'autre question qui me semblent
majeur c'est la question à la fois de la
rénovation du parc du parc dégradé et
puis surtout l'adaptation de la
structure la typologie des logements et
au delà d'ailleurs de du logement
d'habitation aussi de tout le modèle du
logement de la question des services
collectifs qu'on peut produire dans les
logements et quand on va un tout petit
peu dans chaîne dans les pays voisins
il est quand même frappant de voir à
quel point la production française est à
la fois stéréotypé peu créative et
demeure je pense oui de spawn du point
de vue des évolutions de la société
assez inadapté aux besoins mais créative
coopératif aujourd'hui peut-être où on
en parle beaucoup mais veut dire ça se
compte quand même sur les doigts d'une
main
mais tout bêtement oui proposer des
machines à un espace une buanderie
collective dans un immeuble plutôt
qu'avoir chacun
de voir chacun à voir ces machines à
laver ou ce genre de choses aujourd'hui
ça reste quand même marginale dans la
production les plus petits mais en tout
cas vers un espace de vie plus grands
jacqueline ruraux ont parlé d'entretien
aussi un des bailleurs
ça c'est un réel problème notamment dans
les questions d'insalubrité c'est un
problème qui n'est pas forcément du fait
de marchands de sommeil c'est aussi des
propriétaires qui eux mêmes ont du mal à
rénover leur logement
parce que c'est aussi des propriétaires
anciens enfin dès qu'ils n'ont pas eu
l'habitude qui ont loué louer sans se
préoccuper mais c'est pas qui se
préoccupaient pas mais surtout qu'ils
ont vraiment pas les moyens je me
rappelle d'un secteur à cenon où le
maire me raconter qu'il avait même fait
de l'aide à la pierre il avait essayé de
rénover pour les personnes âgées il me
coûte
il me disait que ça coûtait un fruit
était très cher c'était trop cher il
pouvait pas répondre
et dans ces cas là est ce que c'est ces
personnes peuvent faire appel à des
aides de la collectivité où ils sont
arrivés alors il ya là naquit qui fait
un bon travail mais petit à petit en
face et moi ça me paraît trop peu par
rapport
et c'est très long les demandait est bon
il ya des entreprises libyennes mais le
temps que tout ça se mettant en route on
voit bien huit mois 9 mois donc c'est
très long et il ya quand même à un
manque sur le terrain et c'est certes
très important de rénover des périodes
va moi je me rappelle ce merlas il m'a
dit c'est terminé je ne serai pas de
rénover des maisons pour les personnes
âgées ça coûte trop cher voilà et
l'accès et l'accès à ces logements vous
aider beaucoup de personnes à en trouver
aujourd'hui les des logements de la
commune énormément on se bat beaucoup
seulement et ben il ya mille demandes
pour 84 logements privés et des
logements vacants c'est aussi le
problème les logements vacants non pas
220 alors dans sur trois mêmes gellet
j'ai scellé ils sont 200 appartements
libres
voilà c'est une difficulté aussi les
personnes ne veulent pas aller dans ce
quartier voilà il n'est pas bien il est
posté et donc ben voilà il ya les jouets
en vacances dans un quartier où les gens
ne veulent pas les noms pour l arménie
ne trouve pas preneur mais là ce n'est
pas le problème des propriétaires qui ne
veulent pas louer c'est aussi un réel
problème auquel le gouvernement veut
s'atteler jean baptiste eyraud en
incitant en tout cas les propriétaires à
louer
quitte à les inciter à les forcer à
louer est ce que c'est possible sa force
aider des propriétaires privés à allouer
les appartements vides
écoutez toute façon nous on a toujours
dit que il faut mobiliser le parc vacant
dans les zones tendues
bon il faudrait d'abord agir sur le
niveau de loyer
il faut à décourager aussi la
spéculation parce que dans les zones
tendues et ça ce pécule dans tous les
sens le foncier le terrain
et malheureusement les collectivités
territoriales elles sont un peu à
l'avant sur cette question de la
spéculation fait remonter et et cetera
revendre derrière donc et on a on a
entendu comme 2
deux municipalités qui encourage la
flambée la montée des prix immobiliers
bon après les outils pour décourager la
spéculation foncière
or comment il faut faire est-ce qu'il
faut construire davantage de logements
sociaux pour faire baisser les prix
comment est-ce qu'on peut décourager
plafonner les loyers on l'a vu ba
experts d'abord fera arrêter de mettre
du foncier public sur le marché un bon
ça nous paraît une évidence
moi j'ai vu l'a récemment il ya un mois
à peu près 1
là comment on la hollande amsterdam
ils ont interdit la vente de foncier
pour du locatif privé ou pour du bureau
et ils ne l'ont autorisée que pour que
pour la production de logements sociaux
ou pour des gens qui vont y habiter donc
ça c'est une mesure alors dame en droit
français
sans doute est pas encore adapté pour
faire ce genre de choses mais il ya des
outils quand même dur je crois qu'à
vienne aussi ils ont une politique de
contrôle du foncier qui est assez
efficace
un bon et puis on a aussi toujours les
outils la fiscalité c'est à dire qu'on
est quand même très haut tolérant en
france par rapport aux plus values
immobilières
c'est à dire que on achète aujourd'hui
on achète un immeuble
on leur vend ses 3 % sur la privait lui
c'est quand même le loto a été augmentée
oui d'accord mais en attendant la plus
value on a fait je dirais comme disait
mitterrand est inventé on fait de
l'argent dormant
bon il faut de l'argent en dormant dans
l'immobilier c'est extraordinaire quoi
je veux dire bon et ça c'est qu'il n'y a
plus de plus values les les gens ne vont
plus acheter non plus ne croyez pas aux
noms pourquoi c'est si on dit que le
logement c'est surtout pour se loger le
genre pour en faire une marchandise et
gagner de l'argent dessus bon bah c'est
à dire un peu mieux
ça empêche pas enfin on a eu des modèles
quand même sociaux démocrates notamment
les pays du nord en allemagne ou y avait
bon une gestion tranquille sur le parc
locatif y compris le parc locatif privé
c'est à dire on est capable les
politiques publiques sont capables de de
lutter contre clémente et la jungle de
la spéculation immobilière et des
rapports locatifs
on va qu en france on a toujours enfin
je veux dire on a encouragé même les
gouvernements sociaux démocrates qui
sont succédé n'ont pas si bon il ya eu
un peu d'encadrement des loyers parce
qu'on a mis la pression en 2012
bon donc ça y est on a recommencé à
parler de l'encadrement des loyers mais
enfin c'est pas suffisant on va on va on
continue d'en parler bien sûr rester
avec nous et on continue ce débat sur le
mal logement en france on se retrouve
dans quelques minutes est tout de suite
[Musique]
le pire je pense en tout cas
politiquement pour l'union européenne
c'est que ça se passe bien pour les
anglais et y aura peut-être un effet
boule de neige si l'italie sort vous
avez un éclatement de l'euro et de
l'union européenne dans les mois qui
suivent
l'euro s'est pas seulement un projet
financier c'est un projet politique
aussi le rhône fonctionne pas sinon on
n'aurait pas eu ce groupe elle a lu avec
la grèce je suis pas ses mots pas
d'accord sur l'échec de l'euro ou
maintient la grèce en commun à mon avis
une bonne chose vous pouvez pas vous
réjouir d'avoir pays qui est sous
perfusion sous assistance respiratoire
en permanence
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques dans notre pays
et sur ces dossiers sensibles je vais
partager avec vous mon interprétation
quelle que soit la qualité expertise
indéniable nos soldats ils ne peuvent
gagner la guerre pour la raison que je
vais maintenant qu'on peut faire un peu
plus de 5000 militaires français à
l'efficacité certes reconnu sur une zone
aussi vaste même renforcé par cinq mille
soldats promis par les pays vieux 5 0
c'est là où les problèmes ont commencé
les déclarations récentes des politiques
des spécialistes des experts des
militaires montre bien que nous sommes
face à une incompréhension totale entre
les différents acteurs
si la france n'a pas la volonté
nécessaire pour assurer la réalisation
de ses objectifs et de les accompagner
par qu'il ne s'agit pas d'imposer il
s'agit de convaincre et d'accompagner il
est à craindre que nous terminions
enlisé dans un conflit sans fin
[Musique]
pourquoi pas les pagaies la suite avec
jacqueline rue au spécialiste du
logement à l'association familles de
france jean-baptiste eyraud président de
l'association droit au logement et
renault et stein maître de conférences à
sciences po saint germain en laye
spécialiste de l'urbanisme elle la crise
du logement touche des millions de
personnes en france la fondation abbé
pierre a de nouveau lancé un appel au
volontarisme politique fin janvier sdf
privatisation de l'eau ou de chauffage
habitations insalubres lorsque l'on
évoque le mal-logement de quoi
parle-t-on exactement voyez les
explications de notre reporter david
khalifa nous sommes en 2020 et le mal
logement concerne quatre millions de
personnes en france
un constat alarmant qui n'évolue pas
d'année en année le premier indicateur
du mal logement c'est d'abord le manque
d' espaces près de 4,3 millions de
personnes modestes vivant en situation
de surpeuplement dits modérés en clair
il en manque une pièce par rapport à la
norme d'occupation cette norme prévoit
un minimum de neuf mètres carrés pour
une seule personne
seize mètres carrés pour un couple et
neuf mètres carrés par personne
supplémentaire
autre indicateur important le confort
sur les 4 millions de mal logés on
estime à plus de 2,8 millions le nombre
de personnes vivant dans des conditions
de logement très difficiles
le froid fait partie de ces facteurs les
français sont 44 % de plus qu'en 2006 à
se priver de chauffage à cause de son
coût
l'habitat indigne ou insalubres
concernent lui 600 mille logements un
phénomène ne frappant pas seulement les
locataires mais également une part
croissante de propriétaires incapables
de financer des rénovations ou vivant
dans des copropriétés en difficulté
concernant les sans abri il n'existe
aucun chiffre précis et récents la
fondation abbé pierre estime que fin
2010 9 environ 250000 personnes vivaient
en centre d'hébergement d'urgence ou
d'accueil des demandeurs d'asile à
l'échelle européenne il y aurait au
moins sept cent mille personnes sans
abri en 2010
un chiffre en hausse de 70% sur dix ans
cette situation est particulièrement
alarmante dans certains pays comme
l'allemagne qui a dû faire face ces
dernières années à un afflux de réfugiés
qui a gonflé le nombre de sans domicile
sur une nuit la fondation abbé pierre a
répertorié près de 860 milles sdf en
2016 voilà pour le rappel des chiffres
vous voulez réagir à ces chiffres
oh non non juste le chiffre 869 la
fondation abbé pierre n'a pas répertorié
à 860000 par extrapolation à partir d'
enquête partiale ils ont estimé
mélomanes
oui je sais bien oui bien sûr bien sûr
mais bon bref ce qu'on s'est compliqué
et sa red bull sdf on n'a pas de
chiffres fiables je vous la corne on a
on a cherché on n'a pas réussi à avoir
de source précisant les les sources dont
dispose scientifique c'est bon c'est
difficile à quantifier
en revanche ce qui est très clair c'est
qu'on a eu parmi les mal logés une forte
augmentation de la production brute de
deux sdf dans les années 2000 et 2010
je crois que c'est plus 50% soit une
décennie d'après dietrich ragon et
deuxième chose c'est surtout la figure
du sdf on a d'une certaine façon souvent
accord là l'image le vieux clodo vous
les réfugiés les sdf aujourd'hui vous
voulez personnes mal logées de manière
plus générale sont plus en plus des
jeunes et des jeunes en emploi et c'est
c'est la question des travailleurs
pauvres et notamment des jeunes
travailleurs pauvres qui se posent oui
c'est un vrai problème que vous soulevez
on vous le disait à l'image du clochard
a disparu finalement elle est encore là
mais c'est pas le problème aujourd'hui
c'est que on a quand même 74% des
français qui trouvent qu'il est très
difficile de trouver une location
le chiffre est quand même très important
pourquoi cette difficulté d'accès à un
logement
quel qu'il soit c'est vraiment la
question du logement cher en fin de
saison je reviens je repris moi je
prendrais quand j'étais jeune je me suis
logé sans problème à paris bon étudiant
sont particulièrement moi j'ai trouvé ma
piaule de bon après j'ai trouvé un
logement un peu plus grande en secteur
privé et il n'y avait pas de souci allez
un bon ça c'était quoi dans les années
début des années 80 20 des années 70 est
partout en france
on pourrait se loger avec un petit
boulot le même le smic on arrivait à se
trouvent pas à se loger
aujourd'hui le smic ne permet pas de se
loger dans les métropoles c'est dans les
endroits où il ya du boulot
on a donc ce qui fait que là on a dit
hop bon parce que le logement est trop
cher alors après quelles sont les
solutions soit en baisse les loyers si
on dit bon bah au bailleur acea c'est
fini et le système d'encadrement des
loyers aujourd'hui n'est pas suffisant
c'est une évidence un bon donc il
faudrait avoir un modèle de qui amène à
une lan à une baisse des loyers pas
forcément une baisse brutale mais une
baisse des loyers
et puis ce que nous on constate c'est
que les bailleurs sont vraiment épargné
c'est d'ailleurs pris de moins en moins
contrôlé de moins en moins contrôlé par
exemple on a une disposition qui
prévoyait dans les zones tendues le
bailleur n'a pas le droit de louer à un
nouveau look de relouer à nouveau
locataire un prix plus élevé qu'à
l'ancien locataire penser le gel des
relocations qu'elle bailleur respecte
cette disposition et comment l'homme
comment le locataire même qui arrivent
il sait qu'il va il va savoir que le
loyer précédent
donc ça c'est une mesure qui aurait
nécessité évidemment bon quelque chose
que ma répertoire des loyers ou un
répertoire des logements c'est qui
permet aussi de connaître l'état du
logement la surface par mme si on en
quatre vingts faut qu'on connaisse la
surface du logement dont il ya
d'agressif est ce qu'un si elle est
d'ailleurs les bailleurs allait aller
chercher les profits
les revenus locatifs des bailleurs
privés et professionnels c'est terminé
c'est sucré chercher les profits qui a
dans l'immobilier qui sont tirées de les
revendre et transactions des machins là
c'est maintenant si vous les trouvez pas
ça n'existe pas vous allez en cuir orné
comme ça on est sûr devenu public ça la
revente des appartements le non mais les
affiches sur un site
oui ça d'accord mais le problème c'est
qu'après il faut récupérer tous ces
données là et puis il faut calculer que
c'est ira donc si vous normalement c'est
le fisc qui a les informations
bon si appareils sur les revenus
locatifs un bailleur il a il a ici qui
dispose de plusieurs logements
bon il a un forfait bien forfait bon
rayon pop
il a dépensé tant dans les travaux et
caetera et on n'en sait pas plus bon
voila et puis il va payer en fonction de
la totalité des loyers qu'il a déclaré
et des dépenses qu'il a déclaré don quel
système puisse plus de transparence à ce
que c'est ce que voient les bailleurs
privés qui eux mêmes parfois ont peur de
mettre leur logement la faille à cette
histoire-là du fichier des du fichier
des locataires de la peur des impayés de
loyer mais nous c'est ce qu'on dit
toujours un loyer moins cher moins de
risques d'impayés
c'est logique ah bah ouais qu'est ce que
vous pensez les loyers sont chers et
plus il ya des impayés les options
demandé en tout cas pour pouvoir
parvenir à avoir un logement sont de
plus en plus drastiques de la part des
bailleurs privés aussi est-ce que ça ça
empêche la crise logement sans doute
dans certains cas bon il ya quand même
désormais toute une série de dispositifs
de caution que soit funky publics ou
parapublics avec le 1% logement qu'il
faut que c'est cette question elle peut
exister pour certains profils qui
n'arrive pas avant de caution mais elle
est me semble-t-il secondaire derrière
la question qui a été soulevée qui est
fondamentalement l'explosion des prix du
logement alors que ce soit dans le
locatif privé ou ou en accession en tout
cas pour dans les marchés tendus encore
une fois c'est pas le cas partout il ya
plein d'autres endroits dans lequel ces
deux les prix baissent et le fait que
les salaires les niveaux de vie n'ont
pas suivi et donc c'est aussi simple que
ça c'est aussi bête que ça à la question
c'est comment est-ce qu'on résout que ça
comment est-ce qu'on résout ce décalage
qui a désormais qui devient méchant et
nizier dans certaines villes les prix
baissent alors qu'est ce qui les fait
baisser ses prix bas uélé les gens
partent vers les villes dans la caisse
qui sont atteints vous savez
fondamentalement si on considère le
marché privé
c'est un marché effectivement c'est leur
apprendre leur fait la demande qui fait
kiffer et qui fait les prix doux sans
aucun doute l'importance aussi d'avoir
un marché à voir du logement social pour
justement sortir de cette logique folle
qui fait que désormais voilà des délais
classes moyennes n'arrive plus à se
loger dans dans les dents
et métropole et c'est vraiment pour ça
que la relance de la production logement
social est absolument déterminante
et n'oublions jamais logement social
c'est pas de logement pour les pauvres
c'est le jugement qui est accessible
théoriquement et pratiquement les deux
tiers des ménages des ménages français
si on n'arrive pas à relancer ça en tout
cas dans l'est dans les métropoles et
dans les zones tendues sous réserve
qu'on arrive à moi qu'on arrive à mettre
en place des mécanismes d'encadrement
des loyers quand bien même on le ferait
on sait bien travail avoir des effets
sur la réduction de la production de ces
de ses loyers privés et dont on reporte
aussi à moyen terme la crise donc en
l'état actuel la seule solution qu'ont
qu'on aime et c'est même pas une
solution de court terme c'est la
production de logement social et puis à
plus long terme s'est aussi posé une
question sur des politiques
d'aménagement du territoire parce que
pourquoi est ce qu'il ya de tel décalage
entre l'offre et la demande dans les
métropoles c'est parce que on assiste à
un grand mouvement depuis une trentaine
d'années une vingtaine d'années d'afflux
dans ces territoires de concentration de
popularisation de la population dans ces
territoires territoires qui sont déjà
dans son peut pas produire à l'infini en
ile de france
on peut pas produire l'infini à nantes à
rennes à nice etc et donc se pose
aujourd'hui la question de la 2d des
politiques on peut voir bien au delà des
politiques du logement pour organiser un
aménagement du territoire qui va
permettre d'avoir d'autres formes de
développement que le développement
purement metropolit à moreuil à ces
questions là mais bon il n'empêche que
les milieux d'immobilier chaque année
qu'il passe il bat des records de
transactions ils font bombance de plus
en plus bon ben c'est toujours plus
bombance donc si vous voulez faut quand
même aller voir de ce côté là les
inégalités se sont creusées une manière
dramatique même au palais des promoteurs
le milieu de l'immobilier en général ont
choisi avons les uns terme et d argent
intermédiaire
les notaires enfin tout ce qui participe
comme on dit sauf que sauf qu'un appât
ya pas suffisamment de logements sociaux
vous êtes d'accord avec ça oui on est
d'accord mais l'autre question c'est que
on est sur un contexte spéculatif je
veux dire c'est le mot et un rapport de
l'onu début 2018 qui met ça en évidence
c'est à dire que les les
les grandes villes mondiales bon elle
est grande mais les métropoles en règle
générale sont aujourd'hui à des lieux
refuge de l'adc milliers de milliards de
dollars qui se balade dans le monde qui
sont qui gère l'argent des riches des
actionnaires les pensions des classes
moyennes et c est bon qu'ils vont
chercher à s'investir et qui vont
arriver faire de la prédation sur le
parc locatif le parc immobilier et
acheter des quartiers entiers et faire
monter les prix et c'est bon c'est ça
c'est aussi ça c'est un élément qui joue
son wagon t on va écouter à nouveau
pierre pierre madec justement qui nous
parlait de ses fans au propriétaire
écouter sa forme de propriétaires qui
préfèrent garder leurs logements vacants
plutôt que de le mettre en location
il faut voir que là encore les mesures
qui sont prises par le gouvernement vont
pas dans le sens de favoriser la remise
en location d'un certain nombre de
logements parce que par exemple la
réforme fiscale qui est intervenu en
2018 et qui dit au propriétaire si vous
avez un logement que vous le mettez en
location vous serez plus taxé sur les
loyers reçu que si vous avez des
dividendes ou des actions sur les
marchés financiers cela c'est par un bon
signal quand on transforme lisf un impôt
sur la fortune immobilière en disant
pareil on va taxer plus la détention
d'immobilier que la détention de
patrimoine financier c'est par un bon
signal non plus donc l'objectif c'est un
objectif qui est louable c'est à dire
que oui un problème de vacances dans les
zones tendues
et oui faut remettre des logements en
location mais il faut que derrière les
dispositifs fiscaux soit incitatif ce
qu'est ce qui n'était pas le cas avant
2017 ce qui est encore moins le cas
aujourd'hui
jean baptiste eyraud vous parliez des
loyers qui sont chers mais est-ce que
c'est pas ça aussi l'explication c'est
que les propriétaires se font de plus en
plus taxé jacqueline ro
quel constat vous faites justement sur
cette disponibilité sur ses
propriétaires qui hésitent à allouer ou
bas où tu joues trop cher aujourd'hui
bah oui en fait ces personnes là et ils
comprennent enfin moi j'en ai rencontré
personnellement c'est pour ça que je
je suis amené à en parler ses
propriétaires là ils ont toujours peur
caen consolide un petit peu qu'on leur
dit ben va accompagner les familles là
il ya peut-être une ouverture à voir
aussi est-ce que vous les appelez vous
directement c'est à dire j'ai la chance
d'avoir été d'un côté dans de la
copropriété voilà donc je connais un peu
le monde du logement à la fois celle m
est propriétaire est donc incertain où
j'ai interpellé en disant bas essayez
avec cette femme il ya ou la compagne et
dans ces cas là mais c'est d'être aux
petits je sais qu'il ya d'autres des
organismes qui se battent en août dans
ce sens là vraiment d'accompagner les
familles dans le chemin et ça donne
quelque chose tellement quel type
d'accompagnement spécifique que vous
leur ferez alors dans la priorité de
payer son loyer et déjà ses charges et
en fait on arrive parfaitement à aller à
bien les remettre en route parce que des
fois ils se sont écartés
tellement qu'ils ont subi le logement et
du mal logement est vraiment des choses
catastrophiques
quand on leur donne la force l'énergie
et qu'on les accompagne sur le budget
entre autres ben ces personnes-là et
bain et se laisse porter et redémarre
quelque chose de nouveau et elles sont
heureuses et les résultats sont là
ah oui tout à fait jean baptiste eyraud
c'est vrai ce logement ce droit au
logement puisque c'est aussi le nom de
votre association c'est plus un droit
aujourd'hui si ce droit au logement ça
implique beaucoup de choses derrière le
fait d'avoir un poids sur sa tête
oui façon la rue c'est la mort 1 si on
devait résumer c'est quinze ans
d'espérance de vie dans des conditions
de souffrance
on pourrait qualifier on pourrait
comparer de la torture ont une forme de
torture donc bon clairement
quand on laisse les gens dehors on est
on est dans ces criminels quoi d'autant
plus qu'il ya des lois et noah qui est
très clair qui dit que l'état de mettre
en place un dispositif dans chaque
département pour accueillir toute
personne en situation de détresse et la
maintenir et ensuite l'orienter vers une
solution de stabilisation et un logement
donc
or non seulement on n'accueille pas tous
les gens qui sont dehors
1 et deuxièmement on lire fois la rue
bon parce qu'il faut faire tourner
maintenant on fait tourner les classes
qu'est ce que pour économiser et il est
vrai que l'hébergement ça coûte un bras
bon donc voilà maintenant on a deux
milliards d'euros peut-être un peu plus
et on marche sur la tête
enfin je ne sais pas comme ça qu'on
réglera la crise du logement c'est c'est
un puits sans fond bon c'est de pouvoir
payer son chauffage également qu' qui
revient souvent times lui c'est un
élément très important
moi je pense arrêter un français sur
deux il ya été confronté en tout cas une
fois depuis 2006 pour être précis à une
coupure de moi j'ai pas toujours très
chaud chez moi je l'avouer on a des
petits revenus non la famille bon ben
c'est comme ça mais mais c'est dur quand
on a des personnes sont âgées qui sont
malades qu'il ya des enfants en bas âge
et que on peut pas se chauffer ses
dépendances dans un logement humide et
on a des affections spirit oratoire et
puis voilà et veulent aller comment les
souris les rongeurs les cafards et
maintenant les punaises et tout ça enfin
bon et les gens sont envahis et puis les
angoisses de
de la fin de mois il faut payer le loyer
les apl qui baisse non le quotidien
'aujourd'hui d'un locataire modeste qui
n'est pas logés en hlm et en hlm les
choses se dégradent un peu aujourd'hui
je ne sais pas évident et donc ce que
les normes durant ils sont pas celles
d'aujourd'hui le quotidien il est dur
voilà est bon avec an là dessus le
logement touristique airbnb et consorts
la capter une partie du parc parce que
ça fait gagner trois ou quatre fois plus
bon dans les zones touristiques
notamment vous savez nous le sentiment
qu'on ne s'en fait monter les prix des
loyers les bailleurs pas tous les
bailleurs privés mais il ya des
bailleurs privés leur jeu c'est de
gruger gruger d'état gruger les lois
gruger le locataire nous on les voit
jaillir les gens qui arrivent même sur
la surface du logement dont j'envoie des
étudiants architectes pour les faire des
relevés mais il manque toujours 10 à 15
% de la surface s'est passé pourquoi ils
font ça parce qu'ils disent ben oui ben
si ça en si ça non oui c'est ça si ça
encadrent bas j'aurais un petit peu plus
tôt fait quelques locataires à s'en
rendre compte mais c'est pas cueillir
son maître donc je suis tranquille voyez
c'est qu'il ya c'est un sport national
des bailleurs de gruger renault stein
police du logement en france
on parle de je regarde y'a tresses
police de l'habitat dépendant de quatre
autorités administratives différentes
recettes après c'est peut-être trop
technique vous mais voilà il ya quand
même certains contrôles qui sont
effectués le gouvernement souhaite aussi
renforcer les contrôles c'est ce qu'il
dit en vain cas pour vous c'est à un
marché trop qui n'est pas suffisamment
contrôlés je pense que ce soit
essentiellement une question de contrôle
s'est déjà en tout cas de police
nationale mais il faut toujours avoir à
l'esprit que la compétence logement est
une compétence qui a été donnée aux
collectivités en particulier ou commune
et on voit bien que il ya encore une
fois il ya des situations qui sont
extrêmement contrastés pour revenir sur
les situations scandaleuses que vous
dénoncez on voit que on va les observer
de manière massive à marseille et ça
fait l'actualité de ce triste façon il
ya quelques mois rue et rue d'aubagne et
ce qu'on voit apparaître désormais
qu'est ce que c'est c'est que la
municipalité de marseille non seulement
mais la municipalité non seulement n'a
rien fait mais qu' un certain nombre
d'élus marseillais qui est au coeur du
système de godin était d'aider le sont
encore et dans une semaine
et donc voilà on a des marchands de
sommeil qui sont au coeur du pouvoir du
pouvoir municipal
on a quand même énormément d'eau de
ville je suis passé on prend l'autre
extrême on varie aller du côté de la
ville de rennes la métropole de rennes
une ville qui a construit dans la durée
depuis près de trente ans une politique
d'acquisitions foncières de logement
social de logements pour tous des
catégories dans lequel les prix sont
devenus nettement moins élevé que dans
d'autres métropoles comparable dans
lesquels situations mal logement sont
nettement moins moins élevés et donc
puisque votre émission porte quand même
sur les élections municipales
la question du logement pour les
français oui bah à ce moment-là
intéressons-nous et que les français
s'intéressent à ce que proposent leurs
élus les
lui municipaux en termes de politique de
logement et vous verrez que la plupart
du temps ils proposent rien ils vont
avoir des moments dire on va faire du
verre on va surtout pas intensifier tous
les français et la 7ème démission dit
sont conscients du fait qu'ils aient un
problème de mal logement à l'échelon
municipal tous les programmes nous
disent quoi aulas pas de densification
surtout ne construisons pas restons
entre nous pas général assez
spectaculaires ont recensé spectaculaire
il ya un vrai problème du secteur du
logement social et du logement de social
en particulier du logement en général
aujourd'hui tous les maires qui
fonctionnent comme des sortes de syndics
de copropriété en l'expression de pierre
veltz raison alors pour elle parce que
les électeurs disent quoi bein je vais
pas envie d'avoir à côté de chez moi
plus de béton construite construisent
chez le voisin
et donc c'est l'énorme problème sérieux
tant qu'on restera tant que cette
question du logement relèvera d'une
compétence municipale tant que les
maires auront le verrou pour délivrer
des permis de construire on restera dans
la même merde il est vrai ben ça alors
ça je suis d'accord là dessus j'ai moi
aussi
ah ouais vous attaquent modalités voir
élargir d'original c'est certainement
pas les jeux comme non mais même les
élus locaux
par exemple il pourrait prendre la
compétence réquisitions j'en ai pas
parlé mais ensuite on va réquisitionner
faire a priori
ouais bon ça on va voir ce que fait de
normandie - j'attends j'attends avec
intérêt et beaucoup de curiosité savoir
s'il va vraiment réquisitionner des
immeubles dont on connaît dans paris il
y en a désigné quelques-uns
qu'appartient des bons groupes
financiers propriétaire privé ce sont
des groupes financiers aussi que pouvait
bien juteux est bon on attend à louer
parce que bon les petits proprio valeur
de guéret toi tu nous pas ton logement
on va te taxe est méchamment ça va
coûter de l'argent parce que par contre
on a des petits malins qui gardent leurs
logements vides parce qu'ils veulent le
loup et le vendre au meilleur prix au
moment où ils auront envie de le louer
mais ça va être plus sur la spéculation
lourde
bon ben il ya aussi la location le loup
est ce le bal à louer solidaire ou enfin
bombe ces trucs là c'est à dire la
location qui est garanti paiement du
loyer entretien du
du parc et tout et ça c'est un truc que
nous on a on a lancé ça on a été voir ce
qui se passe en angleterre après
l'incendié de l'hôtel opéré en 2005
c'est dramatique est bon a dit mais là
ya pas assez de logements sociaux il
faut arrêter de foot les gens dans les
hôtels et aujourd'hui on pourrait dire
faut arrêter de foot les touristes dans
les logements
c'est un peu ça aussi un bon et bien là
aussi il ya une politique de louis
solidaire on le bail
le solibail que ça ça commence un peu à
prendre mais faut y aller plus quoi
parce que c'est du logement c'est mieux
de mettre une famille dans un logement
et non pas à l'hôtel et tout et c'est
l'hôtel et le bailleur vie et rauque et
il a son loyer qui tombe ça rentrait
tout ça va les accueillir à longs mois
jacqueline gourault cette volonté
politique au niveau municipal vous la
sentez le fait ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure de ne pas vouloir construire de
logements sociaux dans les communes
c'est c'est un bras de fer à chaque fois
alors si on n'aurait pas parlé de dreux
parce que le celui qui était à de votre
expérience en tout cas il a construit
énormément il a rasé tout et ça c'est
moi j'ai trouvé que c'était un tort
puisqu'il y avait des bâtiments encore
bien propre il a rasé pour compte bien
passé pour construire bas de la chaîne
aime bien beau beau mais oui oui oui
voilà amant et sa fuite patrimoine et
ses affaires c'est en gros c'est un gros
problème de fuite de partout j'ai jamais
vue au bout de 10 ans et marié
catastrophe obsolescence programmée
c'est à dire aujourd'hui on se demande
si les promoteurs nous font pas là
l'obsolescence a laissé son nom pensez
vous pensez que c'est la malfaçon mais
il ya aussi doit vous verrez dans dix
quinze ans comment whiskies en français
en allemand et en français en plus en
plus vite et forcément on n'y met pas
forcément la qualité on va passer aux
résultats de notre sondage tout de suite
[Musique]
et on a posé la question sur nos réseaux
sociaux quel est selon vous le défaut
principal de votre logement trop petit
loyers trop chers charges trop élevées
aucun problème dans mon logement voyez
la réponse 47% 48 ce même presque
trouvent que leur loyer est trop cher et
que les charges à 24% sont trop élevés
c'est un sondage évidemment à notre
petit niveau arte france en tout cas on
le voit c'est vraiment ça le problème en
tout cas les loyers qui sont de plus en
plus élevés qui sont un problème
récurrent que faire renault mtein pour
améliorer cela légiférer davantage c'est
ce qu'on a dit pour conclure tout d'un
coup tout le débat comment faire baisser
baisser les loyers sociaux
évidemment pour se faire construire plus
de logements notamment de logements
sociaux dans les marchés tant entendu
évidemment sans aucun doute réguler
les loyers réguler beaucoup plus
nettement fortement en tous cas dans les
territoires tendu l'offre de l'offre
touristique et la prédation airbnb mais
encore une fois je reviens tout ça ne ne
pourra pas de toute façon résoudre un
problème qui est structurelle et encore
une fois tant qu'on ne transformera pas
on n'aura pas des politiques de longue
durée d'aménagement du territoire
sur le long terme qui content c'est
essentiel pour ce faire des mesures
d'urgence comme il faut faire les deux
il faut faire les deux faut appliquer
les lois à respecter les droits des
balles logées décembre ont été conquis
au fil des luttes d'ailleurs
démobilisation des combats parce que le
droit au logement opposable droit
d'hébergement tout ça c'est pas tombée
du ciel
le droit au relogement des habitants de
logements insalubres même la production
de logements sociaux parce qu'en france
on en produit encore pas mal par rapport
à nos voisins européens
moi je dois dire la solution pour nous
elle est simple le jour où il y aura
cent mille ou deux cent mille locataires
dans la rue là ouais on commencera les
voir clair donc 28 mars mobilisation mal
et dans toute l'europe dans toute
l'europe et à des manifestations pour le
droit au logement et contre la
spéculation et le logement se fait noté
jacques miro le mot de la fin si vous
avez un message à faire passer justement
sur ce mal logement contre lequel vous
vous battez tous les jours ben moi
j'espère que les élus entendent les
politiques en temps parce que c'est
désastreux
j'avais rencontré monsieur il ya
quelques années j'avais bonne espérance
et ben on en est toujours au même état a
eu peut-être l'évolution était peut-être
un peu mais pas trop
merci beaucoup merci à tous en tout cas
d'avoir participé à ce débat sur rt
france restait avec nouvelles infos à
suivre
[Musique]